foreign
[Music]
Flames we've all seen these images for
several days at the end of June at the
beginning of July the French Nation once
again experienced a situation of
complete chaos the footage of protests
looting fire and riots that broke out in
France's major cities were seen all
around the world of course these images
are no longer something extraordinary in
this country events and images more or
less similar are repeated every so often
and with increasing intensity it doesn't
matter if we are talking about racial or
religious Vindication and protests the
final of the soccer Champions League the
yellow vests are pension reforms
violence is becoming a distinctive sign
of any social movement in this country
the latest wave of riots triggered by
the fatal shooting of 17 year old nahel
merzuk by a policeman resulted in more
than 5 000 Vehicles burned more than one
thousand properties damaged or looted
269 police stations attacked and more
than 4 000 people arrested it was
Madness even so let's not fool ourselves
because these protests will not really
go down in history
[Music]
in today's friends the latest wave of
violence will be just that the last wave
before the next one comes in the not so
distant future it is something that is
bound to happen and it will probably
happen sooner rather than later because
visual politic Community France is
starting to be broken the country is in
serious danger of implosion and every
now and then the Flames rise up it is as
if France is a pressure cooker each
crisis reveals tensions a conflict in
society our country is constantly
invoking Republican values but it seems
that whole segments of the population do
not feel that this matters to them Bruno
caughtress political researcher and
declarations to Politico the situation
has reached such a point that during the
protests France president Emmanuel
macron went so far as to Advocate ideas
such as these macron suggests blocking
social media during riots but what
exactly is going on in France why do
Society seem to be completely broken
what is behind the huge waves of
violence what consequences are they
likely to have well you see visual
politic viewers in this video we're
going to tell you what are the main
three factors in this chaos that every
now and then is Unleashed in France the
three major ingredients that will allow
us to better understand exactly what is
happening in France and why Paris and
other major French cities are becoming
the Gotham cities of Europe but in this
case obviously there's no Batman in
sight although as we will see some
characters are pretending to be so let's
get cracking
[Music]
the fuse
in order to understand this story we
have to start by going back to the
middle of the 20th century as in many
other large cities in Europe and America
Paris and other large french cities were
expanding at full speed
industrialization and The Exodus from
the countryside to the city were
multiplying urban populations in the
case of France this phenomenon was also
accelerated by the decolonization
processes of its former Empire
in response to the overcrowding of
cities and the appearance of shanty
tones and substandard housing the
suburbs of cities began to grow in the
1960s the famous bong use they did so in
Paris Lyon Marseille and other large
cities they were developed under the
direction of the French State itself
which began to promote thousands and
tens of thousands of social housing
units in these new neighborhoods where
of course schools medical centers and
public transportation links were also
opened on paper this idea was fantastic
foreign
with these new neighborhoods and the
thousands of public housing units built
by the government the poorest French
could not only have access to a house
but also to a much more affluent
lifestyle however problems soon arose
you know that there is a massive gap
between theory and practice and that
good intentions do not guarantee good
results
well initially most of the housing was
designed for the French who had
emigrated from the countryside to the
city but as soon as they could they
moved to neighborhoods considered better
so what happened to those vacated State
housing spaces well they were acquired
by or passed into the hands of the
Immigrant population at the same time
the de-industrialization that Paris had
experienced over the last four decades
had closed the doors to good jobs and
good salaries for many of the residents
of these same neighborhoods and so in
this way these areas ended up becoming
something like a synonym of poverty
immigration and all kinds of problems
School dropouts discrimination
unemployment poorly maintained buildings
delinquency let's just say that little
by little these suburbs started to
become real ghettos
this was a particularly intense
phenomenon for many groups of immigrants
from the Caribbean Senegal Ivory Coast
Morocco and especially Algeria who have
ended up living in separate
neighborhoods where the cultural
pressure of their countries of origin is
maintained and where levels of
integration with French society are
relatively low in recent years for
example many people from countries such
as Pakistan have been arriving and as
you can imagine the combination of such
a rigid culture with a ghetto
environment is a ticking time bomb
no don't think that this has taken
anyone by surprise in 1977 the French
government was already concerned that
ghettos were forming
[Music]
what's more in the last 20 years alone
the French state has spent a whopping 60
billion euros on a colossal campaign to
renovate housing blocks improve
infrastructure and upgrade all kinds of
facilities in these neighborhoods
particularly in the poorest ones where
more than 5 million people live half of
them from Algeria in fact during the
latest protests I'm sure you've all seen
how libraries schools and health centers
were burned and logically if they've
been burned it's because they exist
health is free school is free and
sometimes we have the feeling that it is
Never Enough Emmanuel macron on top of
that for years there have also been lots
of organizations paid by the government
to try to make things better yet despite
all the efforts the results have been
pretty poor the Bon Louis are widely
known for their High rates of
unemployment School dropouts drug
addiction poverty and delinquency it's a
real disaster because many of the people
who live in these places especially
children do not have an easy time
escaping from them and the fact is that
changing material things is relatively
simple all you have to do is pull out
your checkbook however the same is not
true of culture or people do you want an
example well think of the schools
schools in these neighborhoods have very
high failure rates and their academic
level tends to be much lower this means
that many students end up falling by the
wayside
foreign
[Music]
housing policy that ended up promoting
real ghettos is one of the key factors
for explaining why France has so many
problems integrating immigrants
basically immigrants arrive in France
they live in France their children are
born in France but they never really
become French neither them nor their
children at least not completely here
the data is compelling for example it is
estimated that about 50 of the children
in these ghettos are poor unemployment
is almost double the national average
and of course family incomes are much
lower to give you an idea one out of
five foreigners living in France thinks
they are discriminated against because
of their origin their race or their
religion this is one of the highest
rates in the developed World it turns
out that France is one of the countries
that has the most problem integrating
immigrants and these neighborhoods are
largely to blame you don't believe me
well take a look at this graph
foreign
in these neighborhoods and probably a
reality that you don't have as many
opportunities as in other places when
you see your parents and older siblings
struggling to find work we are paying
for the concentration of poverty the
lack of diversity in the schools and the
refusal to build social housing outside
of these neighborhoods Olivier Klein
Minister of Housing and Urban Affairs
and former mayor of Khushi subua a
municipality in the Eastern suburbs of
Paris logically all these factors
generated frustration and make no
mistake frustration is the best possible
fuel for violence
to make matters worse two new problems
have Arisen in these neighborhoods in
recent years firstly drug trafficking
cocaine Supply at an all-time high in
France drug consumption in France has
grown a lot in recent years it is
estimated that cocaine alone has more
than 600 000 regular users in France
this has obviously led to the emergence
of many Underworld groups that operate
precisely from these neighborhoods and
at the same time the there is the
problem of religious fundamentalism it's
precisely in these types of suburbs that
most of the Muslim population of France
lives and think about it the lack of
opportunities the feeling of not
belonging the frustration have formed
the perfect breeding ground where it
comes to recruiting Fanatics for example
I don't know if you remember but before
the pandemic jihadist attacks in France
were the order of the day while most of
them were perpetrated by people of
Algerian origin who lived guess where
exactly in the Bon we this is logically
contributed to an enormous spiral of
distrust violence and suspicion that is
only exacerbated the problem for example
people of foreign origin living in these
neighborhoods are 20 times more likely
to be stopped by police take a moment to
process that 20 times more likely keep
in mind that it's a police force that is
not always particularly friendly which
brings us directly to the second major
factor in this whole story check this
out
[Music]
the police the accelerant
thank you the police force is by far one
of the most powerful institutions in
France among other reasons because it is
strongly unionized the police have a lot
of political influence and in recent
years the rise of jihadist
fundamentalism the increasingly common
protests against the government of the
day and the increase in drug trafficking
has given them even more presence in
society to give you an idea for every
year since the beginning of the century
France has practically passed a new
security law that strengthens the police
for example they can use intermediate
weapons and their Patrols in the suburbs
something that is extremely rare in the
rest of Europe another example they have
been given power to stop and identify
absolutely anyone they want to for
whatever reason they want their powers
even include that since 2017 traffic
police have been allowed to use lethal
Force against anyone fleeing a
checkpoint in fact although it might
surprise you nahel merzuk's case was not
unprecedented on the 7th of June just
three weeks before nahel's death the
Paris Police killed a young woman 21
years old who had allegedly refused to
stop at a checkpoint on the 14th of June
two weeks before nahel's death police
also killed a 19 year old delivery
worker a guy named boy at another
checkpoint in total in just the 18
months prior to the death that triggered
the protest the French police had killed
17 people at traffic controls that is
madness
that's not all in general we are talking
about a police force that accumulates a
lot of complaints for excesses of all
kinds and that as you can imagine is
very unpopular in the suburbs and vice
versa according to polls police officers
surprise surprise disproportionately
identify with parties like Marine Le
pens which are calling for a much firmer
hand in fact after the latest riots
broke out the two big police unions
employed a tremendously inflammatory
tone they went so far as to say that
they were at war against hordes of
savages and that they had to put an end
to the rats well what can I say you can
have whatever opinion you like but I
don't know statements like that don't
exactly seem to inspire cam or
confidence do they the French police are
no joke and that is kind of a joke in
fact keep in mind what macron himself
was saying in 2017. I want to change the
culture management style and recruitment
of the police force Emmanuel macron in
2017. nevertheless not long after came
the yellow vest the pension reform
protests and so on and naturally macron
wanted nothing to do with fighting the
police and especially not with the
unions it was the last thing he needed
of course the fact that the police are
incapable of controlling the suburbs and
that the population of these
neighborhoods has so little confidence
in them only adds fuel to the problem of
the ghettos that we have already seen
hold on just one moment because in this
entire story not everyone loses out the
third major factor in this whole mess is
nothing short of the great beneficiary
of this whole story do you have any
ideas stay tuned
glamor for an iron fist the consequence
the latest wave of violence has resulted
in one clear winner Marine Le Pen the
French are starting to be fed up and Le
Pen has capitalized on this moment like
no one else Le Pen and her party took
advantage of the riots to attack the
macron government but also to present a
package of heavy-handed measures
intended to please the majority of
Voters for example the national rally
formerly the national front Le Pen's
party wants young people from 16 years
old to be able to be tried in criminal
proceedings as adults at wanzo's
convicted of crimes to lose the right to
live in public housing or to receive any
kind of payment or consideration from
the state it also wants many more people
to be imprisoned and to reduce social
payments to people living in the very
suburbs we are talking about and you
know what all of this is starting to
sound good to a lot of French people
remember this is not us saying this on
the 30th of June a poll was conducted
which showed that LE Pen's response had
been the best rated of all political
leaders in France the scum we see
looting stores torching libraries and
City Halls all while laughing are not
doing this for nael it is an excuse to
attack the police and everything that
represents the Republic at Ridge Diaz
Deputy of the national rally despite
everything support for the police has
remained quite High among the French
according to a poll published by the
newspaper Le Figaro 57 sided with the
police while 69 supported declaring a
state of emergency which was by the way
another of Le Pen's demands it's been
quite a political rally visual party
Community the breeding ground that is
emerging in France is
delicate to put it lightly there is
frustration in the suburbs there is
jihadism then we have the most radical
parties Gathering support at full speed
this is the great threat of implosion in
France a country where we can already
find news items like this one fundraiser
for French officer who killed teen
raises over 1.5 million dollars of
course wait a minute because this is not
only happening in France
[Music]
foreign
the truth is that the issue of
emigration and above all the integration
problems that have generated many of the
policies that have been implemented in
recent decades is becoming explosive
material France receives a lot of
attention but it is not a unique case
here on visualpolitik we have already
told you how Sweden is also having
serious problems with violence in this
country for example police have
identified more than 30 000 people who
are either part of or have close
connections to the more than 50 gangs
that have triggered violence within the
country we have never faced such
ruthless criminality the organizational
model of the entire Swedish justice
system is not prepared to deal with such
extensive criminality Anders thornberg
chief of the Swedish national police and
watch out for Belgium or even Germany in
the great European power the number of
crimes has skyrocketed this has caused
the voting intentions of the far-right
alternative for Germany party to shoot
up as well in total of the 27
governments of the European Union only
six currently lean to the left and there
may soon be even fewer in the last 18
months there's been a tremendous
political shift across Europe and here
in immigration and above all the
problems of integration are playing an
absolutely fundamental role so at this
point the key question is over to you
how would you tackle France's problems
immigration is essential and what's more
has very positive economic effects but
how can we improve the integration of
the first and above all the second and
third generations of immigrants you can
leave me your answers in the comments
below and let's open a respectful debate
and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik thanks very much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video
and I'll see you next time
[Music]